- He's a Hong Kong actor, film director,
producer, stunt man, and singer.
- He's known for
performing his own stunts.
- He is a cultural icon.
- He's Jackie Chan and here
are his top ten rules for success.
- I said look, why don't we change
everything opposite Bruce Lee.
Be myself, just me, Jackie Chan.
- That's a lot of confidence.
- [Jackie] Yeah.
- I believe.
- And also I really thank you the producer
he said okay do whatever you like to do.
Yeah, change, no Bruce Lee, comedy.
When Bruce Lee kick high, I kick low.
When Bruce Lee have to
punch, I use pow ow.
- [Interviewer] (laughs)
- Just like normal human being.
Normal when I was young
I'm fighting on the street
one by one, boom I knock somebody down.
Two by one, I knock somebody down.
Three, I run away.
So in the movie do the same thing.
I just everything use in
the movie is my real life.
Choose to do things my own way,
even though I try to get American market
they don't like my idea, they
don't like this kind of humor
martial art fighting, I just insist.
Even to come back to Hong
Kong, I go my own way,
risk my own life, do
the Jackie Chan style.
I never give up even
though I fell down in U.S.
I never give up still.
Not because American market
change my whole style.
After 15 years now the
whole Hollywood action
everybody want to learn from me.
I do the right things.
So I always tell the
people not because one
things fall down you just give up.
Never give up, never give
up, one day you succeed.
In the old day when I
start the action movies
I just make all the laughing, you know,
do all the funny things, you know.
Ow and ooh just and kick their balls.
- Yeah. You can say it, yeah.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- But slowly, slowly from
the audience from the media,
- [Interviewer] Yeah
- Especial from the fans
they write the letter,
oh now I have a baby so
sad I cannot see the movie
because the dirty word,
because the dirty action, because this.
All those years I change,
change, change, change, change.
Without all the dirty things
still can make audience laughing.
- [Interviewr] Yeah.
- That's difficult, it's the audience.
All the fans, all the media teach me
becoming a good film maker.
When you see the famous
people, wow so successful.
You don't know behind the story.
How tough they are, what they ...
Like people wow Jackie the movie so good.
When everybody sleep, I
still in the health club
in the mirror.
- [Interviewer] Practicing.
- Practicing, like this.
And four o'clock, six o'clock and up.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- On the set.
- Then suddenly you do
something, ah, very beautiful.
Oh yeah, go back train again.
Okay, that's a snake head,
that's a snake mouth.
- Yeah.
- That a snake tongue, okay
you create more things.
Some of the crazy stunts
if I think I cannot do it
I already cancel it.
Some really crazy things
I believe I can do it
I already do it.
- [Female Interviewer] Like what?
- Like jump over the building, jump ...
Crash by the hover craft,
jump from the light
72 feet high with no net.
Just so many things, so many things.
Even today I look at a the
old films, look at myself.
Sometimes really smile, I'm glad,
even though I know I get
hurt, I broke my ankle,
I'm so happy I did it.
If today, I cannot do
it anymore, yeah I'm ...
So whatever you want
to do, whatever you ...
I always tell the
students, whatever you do
when you're young, do
it, you might get hurt.
Or you learning a piano or
you're learning a martial art
between ten and twenty, ten
years, learn whatever you can.
Those years, like me, I just do.
Ten years later, now forever
the things you learn are the
the success I have forever.
Don't regret one day, oh
I should do it right now.
No, it's too late.
Do it while you're young.
I think as a producer, director,
we do have a responsibility
for you own society for
your family for the world
so I hope we can unite them
together to make a better movie
for the world, for the
peace, for everything yeah.
Not just making money, money
you cannot live forever.
The movie you can live forever,
everybody can know, yes.
- How do you feel when people copy you.
- No, I'm happy, that means I'm success.
- Okay, but it also pushes you, right?
- And also pushing it,
I want it different.
Like when I doing a
comedy, they do comedy.
When I do action, they're
doing action, okay.
How can I different, okay,
I do dangerous stunt.
Nobody copy me.
- (laughs) Because no one's crazy.
- Then everybody Jackie
you do that we'll do this.
Then I just continue
doing dangerous stunt.
Everyday on the set I
just do the best I can.
Every movie I risk my
life to do the things.
Now, for the beginning
is not for the fans.
- Yeah.
- For myself.
- Because I have to do the best I can.
Then lately, becoming my trademark,
wow Jackie risk his life
and boom boom boom, yeah.
When I'm making a movie after the finish,
after the movie is done,
I ask myself can my
movie show my children.
Yes, then I let my children see it.
Then, if my children can see it
then the whole world children can see it.
I didn't have to go to
school when I was young,
every day was just
fighting, fighting training.
I am a very bad boy,
when I was young, really.
My parents in Australia, just by myself,
everyday what I see all
the Triads, gangsters,
racing car, fighting
people, beating people.
The area of what I see,
so I was very lucky I
didn't join the Triads.
I didn't join the mafia.
- But you could have.
- I could have.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- That's ... all the
friends sit on the table.
Okay, everybody 2-300 U.S., okay, 300.
Then we can sell the drug,
then we can get 900 back.
And then everybody give
300 and Jackie come on.
Then I look at them, I
was like 16 something,
because I promised my father
never get involved with Triad
never get involved with drugs,
never get involved in
the casino, gambling.
I said sorry, I promised my father.
Aw, come on don't be
coward, 300 you can ...
I so sorry, sorry, because
a promise is a promise.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- Then I never get involved
these kind of things.
The best story for me I
think when I was young
and doing Hand of the Dragon
fighting with Bruce Lee
and I was behind the
camera waiting, waiting.
I just see Bruce Lee pow pow pow, pow pow.
Then I just run up, ah boom pow.
Suddenly my eyes all black because
he just one stick right on my head.
Pow, he missed it but I just I do nothing
I just ah, pow, and I just
felt little dizzy but is okay
I look at Bruce Lee, Bruce
Lee doesn't do anything,
he look at everybody and
keep acting, turn around,
back until the director say cut.
Then he just throw the two
stick, just turn around,
Oh my god, he run to me, lift
me up, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
And actually I'm not in pain
anymore because you know
young guy like me, very tough.
But suddenly I don't know why
I just pretend very painful.
I just want Bruce Lee
hold me as long as he can.
During the whole day, every
time he look at me like this.
I say okay, okay, and I
think that the best moment
and somehow he run to
me, what's your name.
I said my name Jackie.
He said what style you learning.
I said southern style,
okay, and talk to me.
Jackie, huh, Jackie, Jackie, okay.
- Thanks so much for watching.
I made this video because MKim asked me to
so if there is a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of Jackie Chan's
top ten rules you loved the most.
Leave it in the comments,
I'm going to join in on the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching,
continue to believe and I'll see you soon.